qué implicaciones tienen estas marchas
para la política rusa y si de alguna
manera ejercen presión real para que el
gobierno de putin libere navalny
y en raúl yo creo que hacen falta dos
dimensiones para la de esta situación
una dimensión interna que tiene que ver
con el grado de oportunidad que
encuentra a la oposición y la valía en
particular para llevar adelante una
suerte de presión relativa frente a un
régimen que tiene un margen importante
de protestas sociales en la situación de
rusia a sus económicamente hablando está
deteriorada las sanciones han hecho su
han hecho mella en la economía y este es
el momento que la oposición que está
fragmentada y no todas se identifica con
la banda y creo que es importante en el
presente considerar que este es un
momento para presionar de género por
otra parte yo creo que hay una dimensión
externa que es importante tener presente
puesto que para el 20n cabeza doblado y
el plan dibise útil existiría una suerte
de traición también proveniente desde
occidente con quien luces se encuentra
en una situación que no es ni de guerra
ni de paz pero considero que hay que
tener presente en esta situación interna
de
de rusia puesto que el régimen considera
que está aquí también funge o un hecho
favorable para que se lleve adelante
estos títulos ahora ante esto que está
pasando entre la posición rusa y le
pregunto si está más fuerte ahora que
hace meses cuando naval y se encontraba
en alemania
bueno yo diría que no es difícil
responder si está más fuerte puesto que
sido nuestra comparación con alguna
movilización particularmente de 2019 si
se va a encontrar con que está más
fuerte y también se va a encontrar con
algunos datos quizás nuevos como que ya
no es solo moscú la protagonista en
materia de movilizaciones sino que las
movilizaciones ocurren incluso antes de
que ocurran moscú en todo el territorio
de rusia e incluso en las zonas más
alejadas de la capital de rusia yo diría
que lo que está aquí poco en el centro
si es que lo que se denomina el modelo
putin o mick que es control político
estabilidad social y eficiencia
económica está teniendo problemas en
estos los últimos segmentos de
estabilidad social y controles
y eficiencia económica